Klingt sauer, ein bisschen krank. Bist du überhaupt in der Lage zu podcasten?
Ja, nach so einer langen Spielpause wollen die Fans sehen, dass ich jetzt wieder voll dabei bin. Und der Trainer hat auch gesagt, ich muss jetzt dabei bleiben.
Direkt live aus dem Trainingslager des 1. FC Logbuch Netzpolitik begrüßen wir euch höherer zu einer interessanten, aufschlussreichen, aufregenden, spannenden und erhaltsamen und ausgefallenen Sendung.
Und ganz besonders begrüßen wir heute Manuel, Andre und Sebastian.
Die sich mal wieder hervorgetan haben.
Die haben sich wieder hervorgetan mit hervorragendem Engagement für die Netzpolitik.
Ja, das ist begrüßenswert. Also so ein Einsatz. Also manchmal, dass ja auch die Leute dir in den letzten Minuten einfach noch Tension verbringen und das Ruder rumreißen. Gerade wenn man noch geglaubt hat, jetzt wäre man raus, geht es dann doch noch mal eine Runde weiter.
Das ist dann auch gut fürs Pressing.
Also ich denke, mit so Fußball-Assoziationen kann man hier doch eine ganze Menge reißen.
Ja, also das Universum der Fußball-Assoziationen ist groß.
Das ist auch gut für den Teamgeist. Ja, wir sind so beide so ein bisschen so, aber muss ja.
Ja, gute Freunde kann niemand trennen.
Ja, und es sind einfach 60 Minuten und danach... Also üblicherweise reißen wir doch immer die Stunde. Also mein, wir können uns hier auch zwei Halbzeiten aufteilen. Machen wir das halt heute mal.
Heute machen wir zwei Halbzeiten, ja.
Genau. Ja, dann würde ich sagen Anpfiff, oder?
Anpfiff heute für die Türkei.
Ja, die kämpft ja immer noch um die Qualifikation, auf diesem Planeten. Dann müssen wir echt aufhören.
Ernstes Thema, ernstes Thema.
Ich nehme mich schon zurück.
Und zwar wollte ich heute diese Sendung nutzen, um das zu erklären, wie es in der Türkei ist, mit dem Internet.
Nämlich Scheiße.
Und ich habe nämlich ein paar Interviews gegeben, dann letzte Woche, unter anderem Bayerischen Rundfunk und Associated Press und was nicht alle. Und die wollten alle auch nicht auf mich hören, weil die wollten alle die Geschichte schreiben, dass die türkische Bevölkerung sich ja gerade über die Netzsperren in der Türkei kaputtlacht, weil die so leicht zu umgehen seien. Und ich hab dann eine halbe Stunde auf die Frau eingeredet, um am Ende mit einer, zwei kurzen Sätzen in ihrer Radiosendung aufzutauchen. Und jetzt hab ich mir gedacht, mit meiner eigenen Radiosendung kann ich das in meine Ruhe erklären. Das ist nämlich so.
Das ist wieder ein schönes Beispiel, wenn quasi schon die Agenda vorher gesetzt ist. Wir wollen jetzt das berichten und jetzt suchen wir einfach nur noch den passenden O-Ton und das auszukleiden. Und am Ende ist es überhaupt nicht wichtig, was noch erzählt wird. Wenn ich regelmäßig mit Pressearbeit zu tun hab und bei mir ich bin jetzt auch nicht regelmäßig damit zumindest derzeit hab ich keinen regelmäßigen übermäßigen regelmäßigen Pressekontakt. Aber wenn man da in irgendeiner Form eingebunden ist, was ich von Zeit zu Zeit mal hatte, dann merkt man das eben sehr schnell, dass es eben sehr häufig genau nach diesem Muster geht.
Ja absolut, die haben alle ihre Geschichten schon vorher fertig.
Story im Kopf.
Möchten da auch nichts dran ändern. Naja, also wir haben ja mitbekommen, die Türkei sperrt jetzt in dieser Zeit gerade Twitter und wollen mal so ein bisschen beleuchten, wie es dazu kam. Denn schon seit 2007 gibt es in der Türkei ein Gesetz für Internetüberwachung und Netzsperren. Ich glaube, die Rospertasse brauch ich heute öfter. Und sie sperren derzeit schon über 40.000 Webseiten.
Hm, 40.000. Das geht auf jeden Fall schon mal deutlich unter in der aktuellen Berichterstattung. Man hat so diese Eindruck so, oh ja, also Internet, alles super, aber nur Twitter ist doof.
Genau. Und sie haben dann irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren schon einen neuen Filtermechanismus eingeführt, wo also vorher war es so, dass man filtern musste und man konnte auswählen zwischen Standard, Familie und Kinder. Das waren so die drei Filter. Du als Kunde konntest das irgendwie quasi, du konntest dir aussehen, wie viel du zensiert werden möchtest.
Achso, man ruft dann beim Start an und sagt, hallo, ich hätte heute jetzt gerne mal das Standard-Programm.
Ist ja auch so ein Ding, das macht ja nicht der Start, sondern das machen ja die Internetprovider auf geheißtes Startes.
Also muss man seinem ISP anrufen und sagen...
Genau, du kriegst Standard und wenn du irgendwie Familie und Kinder, Familie oder Kinder haben willst, dann musst du halt irgendwie sagen, schaust du dir den noch. Dann gab es irgendwie Massendemonstrationen und Aufschrei. Und dann wurde gesagt, okay, dann wird dieses Filtern optional. 4-5% der Internetnutzer haben das dann überhaupt noch genutzt. Aber diese 40.000 Websites, von denen waren größtenteils auch ohne Filter die meisten nicht erreichbar. Klassisches Ding, ach so ihr wollt die Filter nicht mehr. Kein Ding, lassen wir die Filter weg, machen wir nur noch Zensur. Das Spiel geht da immer weiter. Es wird gesagt, dass auch vorher schon ohne Gerichtsbeschluss einige Seiten auf dieser Liste gelandet sind. Das war jetzt gerade diese Gesetzesänderung, die dann vor ein paar Monaten war, die du immer auch, oder vor ein paar Wochen, die du immer auch im Logbuch behandeln wolltest. Und ich irgendwie gesagt habe, quatsch, die filtern eh schon so viel. Das ist jetzt nicht wirklich eine große Neuigkeit.
Jetzt haben wir Neuigkeiten.
Genau, jetzt haben wir Neuigkeiten. Und zwar wird der Ministerpräsident Erdogan ja von immer neuen Enthüllungen via YouTube-Heim gesucht, wo Gespräche von ihm am Telefon, glaube ich, größtenteils wiedergegeben werden oder Aufzeichnungen dieser Gespräche wiedergegeben werden, die die Korruption in seiner kleinen Oligarchie, die er sich da aufgebaut hat, zutage fördern. Und Ergebnis war jetzt, dass das durch den Ministerpräsidenten angeordnet, oder nee, durch den Ministerpräsidenten angekündigt und kurz darauf von einem Gericht angeordnet, eben eine Sperre von Twitter vorgenommen wurde. Genau, und das war genau der Punkt, wo dann alle anriefen, und zwar, wollte ich das jetzt vielleicht auch kurz ein bisschen technisch erklären, wenn ein Computer, der mit einem Netzwerk verbunden ist, zum Beispiel dem Internet, bekommt hier, braucht ja, korrigiere mich, wenn ich falsch rede, braucht drei Sachen. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal drei, vielleicht sind es vier, warte. Also er braucht eine eigene IP-Adresse. Er braucht eine IP-Adresse, durch die er gerne routen möchte.
Also ein Gateway oder ein Default-Router.
Das reicht eigentlich schon für Verbindungen, ein Subnet noch, aber das ist eigentlich eher eine Einstellung. Also brauchst du ein Gateway und brauchst eine eigene IP. Das Gateway muss zu dir routen und du zu dem Gateway, das Gateway pingen können. Dann hast du quasi schon Internet.
Das ist aber noch ein bisschen unpraktisch, weil an der Stelle müsste man halt immer nur mit Adressen arbeiten. Also will man noch was haben, was einem dann die schönen Namen auflöst.
Genau, denn zu dem Zeitpunkt könntest du nur zu den IPv4- oder IPv6-Adressen gehen. Was du aber haben möchtest, ist, dass du in einen Browser schön bunt eingeben kannst. www.twitter.com statt einer der IP-Adressen. Genau, aber wir bleiben jetzt bei Twitter, weil ich glaube, wir sind schon längst in der Türkei geblockt. Und deswegen wollen wir bei dem neuen Fall bleiben. Aber da kommt nämlich dann dieser dritte Teil, den man gemeinhin braucht, damit ein Rechner als mit dem Internet verbunden seinem Nutzer auch erscheint. Nämlich ein DNS-Server, Domain Name System Server, der genau diese Übersetzung macht von www.twitter.com in die IP-Adresse von Twitter. Und das ist eine zentrale Anlaufstelle für all euren Datenverkehr, wo ihr zumindest am meisten auch über euch selber verratet. Deswegen operiert jetzt zum Beispiel auch Google einen DNS-Server. Aber da kommen wir nachher zu. Was üblicherweise passiert ist, wenn euer Handy sich mit dem Internet verbindet oder euer Heimrouter, also zum Beispiel eure Fritzbox, kriegt sie genau diese drei Sachen. Eine IP-Adresse, ein Gateway und ein DNS-Server. Das ist üblicherweise der DNS-Server des Anbieters, bei dem ihr seid. Also euer Internetanbieter unterhält in der Regel einen DNS-Server. Und dieser DNS-Server weiß nicht alle Domains und die dazugehörigen IP-Adressen, aber so ungefähr alles, was in letzter Zeit durch ihn angefragt wurde. Und wenn er was nicht weiß, fragt er bei anderen DNS-Servern nach, die dann für diese Domain zuständig sind.
Also mit anderen Worten, dieser eine DNS-Server ist quasi die One-Stop-Adresse. Also der einzige direkte Ansprechpartner und alles andere, alle Auskünfte, die der nicht sich sofort aus irgendeinem Rippen oder aus dem Cash ziehen kann, die werden dann halt in dem Moment, wo sie erfragt werden, nochmal eingeholt. Aber das ist alles komplett transparent für den Nutzer, also man merkt da nichts von.
Genau, also diese DNS-Abfrage funktioniert quasi als Teil des Seitenaufrufs. Und was jetzt in der Türkei gemacht wurde, ist, es wurde den türkischen Internet-Providern gesagt, Freunde, wenn euch jemand nach twitter.com fragt, dann gebt ihr dem bitte nicht die IP zurück, die zu twitter.com gehört, sondern eine andere, nämlich eine, die irgendwie der türkischen Regierung gehört und wo dann eine Sperrseite angezeigt wird. Das ist erstmal ohne Weiteres möglich, aber natürlich sehr ungehörig. Und was dann getan wurde, was die Nutzer dann gemacht haben, ist, sie haben statt des ihnen von ihrem Internetanbieter vorgegebenen DNS-Fervers einfach einen anderen eingetragen. Das kann man bei seiner Fritzbox machen, das kann man bei seinem Betriebssystem machen, kann man also auf verschiedenen Ebenen dann eben einstellen. Interessanterweise habe ich das auf dem iPhone nicht gefunden, diese Einstellmöglichkeit. Vielleicht war ich zu blöd, sie zu finden, aber ich glaube, zumindest für die Datennetzverbindung kannst du es nicht einstellen. Du kannst das für die WLAN-Verbindung machen, aber nicht für die 3G-Verbindung.
Das kann gut sein, ja.
Interessanter Punkt, weil natürlich dieses gesamte Twitter-Zeug eine hochgradig mobile Angelegenheit ist. Das heißt, das ist natürlich ein Problem für die Nutzer, wenn das Telefon eine derartige Einstellung zur Umgehung der Zensur nicht ermöglicht. Denn genau, was die Nutzer gemacht haben, sie haben dann einfach den vermutlich unzensierten Google-DNS-Server genutzt mit der IP-Adresse 8888. Und dieser hat den Vorteil, dass er in der Regel sogar noch schneller ist, als der, den der Provider bereitstellt. Und wie gesagt, unzensiert ist. Und außerdem noch Google dabei hilft, euer komplettes Verhalten im Netz zu überwachen, sodass Google mehr Daten vor euch hat und die Qualität der Werbeanzeigen, die ihr von Google präsentiert habt, präzisiert bekommt, auch noch steigt.
Ich glaube, ich kann lange darüber diskutieren, warum Google diesen 8888-Dienst angeboten hat, was ich an sich schon mal für einen großen Wurf gehalten habe. Also jetzt einfach aus ihrer Perspektive heraus. Sehr wohl ist das natürlich auch im Prinzip genau ein Angebot, genau in dem Moment, wo eben einfach bestimmte Dinge wegzensiert werden. Also es ist quasi, ich glaube nicht, dass es die einzige Motivation ist von Google, aber ich denke, dass es schon eine der primären Motivationen ist, eine Alternative zu DNS-Servern zu bieten, die einfach, naja, salopp formuliert, fehl konfiguriert sind, etwas klagender, mahnender, eben einfach so ein Verhalten an den Tag legen, was nicht nur nicht in Google ist, sondern eigentlich auch in jedermanns Interesse nicht sein kann. Also wir haben ja zum Beispiel hier in Deutschland auch den Fall, dass, wenn man jetzt eine Domain-Adresse eingibt, die es nicht gibt, diese DNS-Server dann eben ganz frechlich nicht sagen, hier Fehler, gibt's nicht, der Browser einfach eine Fehlermeldung anzeigt, so wie er sie eben bekommt, sondern stattdessen dann auf eine andere Webseite verwiesen wird, wo dann der Provider mit, oh, hast du dich vertippt? Meintest du vielleicht, ach, und übrigens hier haben wir auch noch ein paar Werbung, ein bisschen Werbung für dich, vielleicht war das ja das, was du wolltest.
Ja, das ist echt unmöglich.
Ja, also das ist ohnehin schon seit längerem so ein, ja, so ein noch nicht ausreichend bestraftes Verhalten. Es wird dann immer schön als, naja, wir helfen ja dem User und so weiter verkauft. Das ist natürlich alles Bullshit. Stattdessen wollen die Leute eben, also wollen diese Anbieter einen auf irgendwelche Portalseiten verweisen, um da weitere Views und Klicks und was nicht alles zu bekommen. Und das ist natürlich hoch problematisch, zeigt aber eigentlich auch sehr schön, welche Kraft man an der Stelle hat, weil im alten Internet, in diesem IPv4-Internet ist man eben auch noch sehr viel mehr abhängig von so einem DNS-Server als in einem möglichen zukünftigen V6-Netz.
Genau, also DNS, man könnte das, also auch ein großes Sicherheitsrisiko. Man schenkt seinem DNS-Server auch relativ viel Vertrauen. Also wenn der eine falsche Antwort liefert, gibt es im normalen DNS jetzt keine manche Möglichkeit, das zu...
Man verrät auch relativ viel über die eigene Interessenswelt, weil so jede Webseite, die man besuchen möchte, jeden Dienst, den man irgendwie mit welchem Protokoll auch immer ansprechen will, egal wie viel Verschlüsselung man benutzt, man sagt vorher in der Regel relativ unverschlüsselt, ja, hier gib mal...
Sag mal, die IP zu der Domain.
Hätte ich gern, brauch ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Und das ist ja glaube ich auch genau der Grund, also ich bin da ja sehr viel kritischer. Ich glaube, das ist der Grund, warum Google das gemacht hat, weil sie zwar einerseits so schon dein gesamtes Browsing-Verhalten sehen, weil du jedes Mal irgendwie alles, wo du hin willst, oder der Gemeinnutzer erstmal alles bei Google eintippt und dann draufklickt, das heißt, Google weiß, wonach man sucht und für welche Seite man sich dann entschieden hat. Aber wenn man, bevor es 8888 gab, irgendwie durch etwas gemacht hat, was nicht das Web berührt hat, zum Beispiel E-Mails abholen oder jabbern oder ICQ oder sonst irgendwas, oder auch einfach nur Bookmarks aufgerufen hat aus seinem Browser, dann hat Google davon nichts mitbekommen, so bekommen sie es mit. Also es gibt viele Gründe. So ein DNS-Server ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz interessante Angelegenheit. Wir schweifen so ein bisschen ab. Wir fordern natürlich einen DNS-Server, der nicht manipuliert ist, der uns weder im Fehlerfall auf irgendeine Werbeseite umlenkt, noch im Twitter-Fall auf irgendeine Regierungsseite. Und genau diese Forderung erfüllt erst mal dieser Google-DNS. Und den haben natürlich dann auch viele Nutzer eingestellt bei sich. Das war dann so, da gab es dann große Graffitis auf den Plakaten mit Spuldose draufgeschrieben. Acht, acht, acht, acht. Weil man sagen muss, in der Türkei mit diesen Straßenparolen, die sind immer nach kürzester Zeit weg. Die werden immer nachts dran gespült von den Leuten. Und tagsüber werden die sofort von den, in der Regel Geschäftsbesitzern und Hausbesitzern, sofort übermalt. Genau, damit die keinen Ärger kriegen. Weil die nicht irgendwie die Idioten sein wollen, die das an ihrem Haus stehen lassen. Also das muss man jede Nacht neu dran sprühen. In der Türkei ist echt krass. Das nur im Rand. Also auf jeden Fall zu diesem Zeitpunkt riefen sie mich dann an und sagten, ja hier und ist das nicht, ist die Türkei nicht blöd, so dämliche Sperren zu machen und hahaha, die Nutzer lassen sich von der Regierung nicht einschüchtern und was nicht alles. Und das ist natürlich eine sehr, also diese Einstellung, da hab ich die Journalisten dann auch sehr stark gerügt und hab gesagt, so Freunde, so kann man nicht damit umgehen, wenn Staaten irgendwie anfangen unsere Meinungsfreiheit in dem Ausmaß zu beschneiden. Denn was sie als nächstes machen werden, ist sie werden genau, entweder jetzt genau überwachen, wer nutzt den Google-DNS. Das heißt, statt Zensur, also erstmal grob die 80% wegschneiden durch Zensur, die verbleibenden 20% überwachen und identifizieren, weil sie diese Zensur gerade umgehen. Und dann werden sie diese Umgehungsmöglichkeit natürlich auch dicht machen, indem sie eine IP-Sperre auf 8888 machen.
Das ist schon geschehen.
Und das ist dann am nächsten Tag auch geschehen. Das heißt, sie haben, sie unterbinden jetzt die Kommunikation zu diesem einen DNS-Server, der eine Umgehung ermöglicht. Jetzt könnte man natürlich wieder hingehen und sagen, ok, dann suchen wir andere DNS-Server. Zum Beispiel einen vom Chaos Computer Club oder von anderen Internet-Providern aus anderen Ländern. Aber es ist davon auszugehen, dass auch das irgendwann dicht ist. Denn es ist eine relativ einfache Umleitungsregel. Einfach alles, was eine DNS-Anfrage, also UDP-Port 53 ist, sowieso an einen bestimmten DNS-Server umzuleiten. Und es ist davon auszugehen, dass das das nächste ist. Und selbst wenn sie das nicht täten, würden sie eventuell einfach den gesamten IP-Block von Twitter sperren. Und dann spätestens sind die Nutzer so weit, dass sie nicht mehr mit einfachen Konfigurationsänderungen diese Sperre umgehen können, sondern dann müssen sie Tor nutzen oder einen VPN.
Ist es nicht sogar schon so weit, dass sie jetzt auch den IP-Range von Twitter sperren? Ich dachte, wir wären schon so weit.
Ich dachte auch, wir wären so weit, aber ich habe die Meldung noch nicht gesehen, dass sie das täten. Aber es ist nur eine Frage der Zeit. Vielleicht habe ich die auch überlesen, weil ich gestern nicht aufmerksam genug gelesen habe. Aber das ist natürlich das, was sie als nächstes tun werden. Es sei denn, sie entscheiden sich für die andere Strategie, nämlich zu sagen, uns reicht, wenn diejenigen, die die Sperre umgehen, kein Publikum mehr erreichen und wir sie dafür überwachen und identifizieren können. Und sie dann beim nächsten Mal einen vor die Mappe kriegen, wenn sie auf die Straße gehen.
Ja, ich meine, die Situation in der Türkei ist ohnehin etwas verworren, weil etwas, was du noch gar nicht erwähnt hast, was an der Stelle, was vielleicht die meisten wissen, aber was nochmal ganz wichtig ist in dem Zusammenhang, wir stehen ja unmittelbar vor den nächsten Wahlen. Das ist zwar nur die Kommunalwahlen, aber von denen geht halt ein wichtiges Signal aus. Erdogan ist halt ausreichend nervös, zumal es eben auch den Anschein macht, dass all diese Telefonmitschnitte, die dort veröffentlicht wurden, sehr wohl auch stimmen. Teilweise hat er das ja selber auch zugegeben. Also er hat natürlich erstmal alles abgestritten, dass die Stellen, wo er, was weiß ich, seinem Sohn gesagt hat, hier holen wir die Millionen unter dem Bett hervor und bringen die mal in Sicherheit etc. und so Repressalien in die Richtung unternehmen, die halt nicht die Regierungslinie nachvollziehen. Das hat er natürlich alles abgestritten. Hat dann aber quasi im selben Zuge beklagt, dass er abgehört wird. Also flüchtet sich dann immer so ein bisschen in dieses Jahr, das sind ja alles Collagen und ihm wird ja da was in den Mund gelegt und so. Und hat also jetzt quasi das Internet so als Feind ausgemacht. Und das ist natürlich dann auch wieder dieser klassische Streisandeffekt, wobei das ist jetzt der Punkt, den ich nicht einschätzen kann. Mir ist nicht klar, wie omnipräsent diese Wahrheit in der Türkei ohnehin schon ist. Also das hat ja auf jeden Fall Welle gemacht. Es gibt natürlich einen gewissen Teil der Medienlandschaft, vielleicht sogar einen großen, das weiß ich nicht, der das Thema entweder totschweigt oder noch relativiert. Einen anderen, kleineren, der das eben auch skandalisiert. Und was die Leute jetzt wirklich denken und in welchem Maß sie das tun, insbesondere wie sehr verkopft jetzt diese klassischen Unterstützer von Erdogan sind und da einfach seine Linie im Prinzip nachziehen und sagen, ja das ist ja alles gelogen und was im Internet gesagt wird, ist gelogen und da muss man auch gegen vorgehen, also sie das ja auch unterstützen. Diesen Kampf, den kann ich nicht so richtig einschätzen. Das findet auf jeden Fall auf beiden Seiten statt. Also es ist quasi auf der einen Seite dieser Vorwurf. Andererseits zieht ja gerade so ein Verbot dann immer eigentlich nach sich, dass dann eben noch mal ein besonderes Interesse darauf geleitet wird, dass dieser Streisand-Effekt, wie man das so schön nennt, benannt nach Barbara Streisand, also der Hollywood-Schauspielerin und Sängerin, die ja mal, ich glaube, seinerzeit mal Fotos von ihrem Anwesen auf dem Netz rausklagen wollte, was natürlich dazu führte, dass das Internet vollgestopft war mit ihren Fotos und sie quasi dann diesen Verbreitungseffekt, den sie eigentlich nicht haben wollte, nochmal künstlich befeuert hat. Das war jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht bei Erdogan auch der Fall. Die Frage ist nur, ob das noch irgendwas groß ändert, weil mir scheinen die Fronten da sehr festgefahren zu sein.
Also, vorsichtige Analyse der Situation in der Türkei, so wie ich das damals erlebt hab, als ich letztes Jahr da war, es scheint eher so eine Art Klassenkampf zu sein oder Schichtenkampf zu sein, nämlich dass die aufgeklärte Mittelschicht, so Leute, die Zugang zu einem ungesund hohen Maß an Bildung hatten, wenn man jetzt aus einer Demokratur darauf blickt, dass das diejenigen sind, die also quasi diese freiheitliche, anti-autoritäre, diese demokratische Revolutionsbestrebung da anführen, während es einfach eine sehr viel größere, sehr viel weniger gebildete Schicht gibt, die sich relativ einfach mit so konservativen Plattitüden und irgendwie mit sehr viel Bezug zu ihrer Religiosität da recht einfach kontrollieren lässt. Und ob der Streisand-Effekt jetzt irgendwie auch für diese anderen Gruppen gilt, wage ich zu bezweifeln. Und so verkauft er das ja auch. Er stellt sich ja irgendwie hin und sagt, ja, hier, die Türkei steht stark gegenüber dieser US-Propaganda, die hier unsere religiösen Werte unterwandern möchte. Und da scheint es auch tatsächlich Leute zu geben, die das dann toll finden, dass die Türkei vor diesem schädlichen, gottlosen Einfluss geschützt wird. Er hat da auch tatsächlich Fans und Unterstützer. Übrigens auch interessanterweise, wenn man sich in Deutschland mal umhört, also unter türkischen Familien, die in Deutschland wohnen, gibt es relativ, also so Unterstützung von Erdogan ist da jetzt nicht unbedingt selten vorzufinden. Man würde ja eigentlich genau das Gegenteil meinen, dass die in Deutschland lebenden türkischen Familien da jetzt irgendwie so die Revolution im Heimatland sehen und sich freuen, dass sich da was ändert. Ist aber nicht so, dass das jetzt irgendwie die Mehrheit zu sehen wird. Aber wir schweifen total ab. Also was in so einer Filtersituation immer zu beklagen ist, egal wie dilettantisch sie gemacht wird, ist, dass sie trotzdem den größeren Teil der Menschen betrifft und die nicht das umgehen. Allein die Änderung des DNS-Servers ist etwas, was sehr, sehr viele Menschen erst mal überfordert und vielleicht auch sie in eine Situation bringt, dass sie gar nicht erst diese Motivation verspüren, das zu tun. Wenn entweder die Tweets in den Artikeln eingeblendet werden oder eben nicht, sie sind jetzt keine besonderen Twitter-Nutzer, also bleibt diese Information ihnen vorenthalten. Und das ist das Gefährliche an so einer Zensur. Nicht, dass es theoretisch immer eine Möglichkeit gibt, das zu umgehen, wo wir dann ohnehin bei einem Wettrüsten sind. Ja, wenn jetzt die Nutzer anfangen, wie die Wilden, jetzt VPNs aufzumachen und so, dann werden halt die VPN-Anbieter gesperrt. Ich meine, wenn du erstmal eine Filterinfrastruktur hast, die 40.000 Webseiten sperrt, dann ist jetzt irgendwie 2-3 VPN-Anbieter, ist auch kein Problem. Vor allem, wenn du immer schön gemütlich 3 Tage warten kannst, bis sich genug Leute für diese Option entschieden haben und dann erst den Hahn abdrehst.
Jetzt gab es ja eine Gerichtsentscheidung, nach der diese Sperrung wiederum unzulässig sei. Also der aktuelle Trend in der Türkei ist jetzt auch gerade mal wieder, dass die Gerichte sich das jetzt nicht beliebig vorschlagen lassen. Mal sehen, wie lange das Bestand hat. Es wurde auch gesagt, na ja, jetzt müssten im Prinzip die Sperren wieder zurückgenommen werden, aber das könnte jetzt auch noch ein wenig dauern. Also die Verschleppungstaktik scheint da auf jeden Fall auch noch eine Rolle zu spielen. Ist immer schön. Man kann also innerhalb von Stunden so eine Sperre aufsetzen, aber sie wieder zu entfernen, das ist total schwierig. Was weiß ich, vielleicht ist da noch jemand im Urlaub, man weiß es ja nie.
Na ja, aber du hast sogar recht, in den Artikel habe ich auch gelesen, da steht auch drin, dass jetzt eigentlich, dass der Vollzug vorläufig aufgehoben ist. Und das kann man natürlich interpretieren, dass sie sie auch wieder ausgemacht haben. Aber ich weiß nicht, ob es tatsächlich...
Berichte davon mag es geben, aber haben wir uns jetzt zum Zeitpunkt der Eintütung dieser Sendung nicht erreicht.
Ja, also sowas ist immer schwierig, sowas ist immer kritisch. Und was man nicht vergessen darf, ist, spätestens wenn sie dann zu IP-Sperren greifen, dann kommen sie auch zu so relativ großen Kollateralschäden. Also du kannst sagen, ok, wenn du jetzt, sagen wir mal, meine Website, mein Blog liegt auf einem... Dann kann man entweder sagen, man killt diesen DNS-Eintrag, dann könnten aber alle sagen, ha ha ha, dann fragen wir halt Google und dann kommen wir trotzdem dorthin. Oder man könnte sagen, ok, dann sperren wir halt diese gesamte IP. Dann sperrt man aber die 150 Leute, die mit unter der IP hosten, gleich mit aus.
Das heißt da, beziehungsweise wird ja nicht selten, wird ja dann auch wirklich ein kompletter Provider auch mal abgeschnippelt.
Nicht selten werden auch komplette Provider abgeschnippelt, kommt immer darauf an, wie unterschwellig man vorgehen möchte. Allerdings, die technischen Möglichkeiten bewegen sich ja auch in eine andere Richtung, nämlich dahin, dass das böse, die Packet-Inspection eine Rolle spielt. Wo also dann statt dieser einfachen Regeln, ok, eine DNS-Anfrage dahin wird falsch beantwortet. IP-Verbindungen zu der Adresse werden irgendwie nicht weitergeleitet. Gibt es dann in neuartigerem Netzwerkequipment eigentlich schon immer standardmäßig eingebaut, die sogenannte Deep Packet Inspection, wo zum Beispiel Regeln möglich sind, die einzelne URLs sperren, dass man sagt, ja, du darfst auf YouTube, aber wenn du auf YouTube genau diesen einen Wert, diese eine Seite besuchst, dann kriegst du keine Antwort mehr durchgeleitet. Du darfst, was auf Protokollebene eben ein für die Sperrinfrastruktur daher eine Herausforderung ist, weil explizit sie ja eigentlich nur gefragt werden, wo ist YouTube und schick mal dieses Paket dorthin. Und in diesem Paket fragt man dann den YouTube-Server, übrigens gibt mir doch mal bitte Video 500, und quasi auf dieser tieferen Ebene des Paketes, des Traffic-Paketes zu schauen, was will der Nutzer sich da gerade genau holen. Das ist dann eben diese Deep Packet Inspection, mit der man dann wirklich allerlei bösartiges Schindluder betreiben kann und die nicht etwas ist, was man optional neben sein Netzwerkequipment stellt, sondern die etwas ist, was ja zu den ganzen neuen Routern, die bei den Providern in die Regale gestellt werden, schon mit eingebaut haben. Einfacher Grund dafür ist, die brauchen ja auch einen Grund, neue Router zu verkaufen.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, was du darüber weißt, aber meines Wissens gab es ja auch schon Sperrungen von YouTube in der Türkei.
Ja, und die waren auch URL-basiert teilweise. Also die YouTube-Sperrung in der Türkei ist auch so ein lustiges Ding. Es gab irgendwie vor Jahren den Fall, dass ich glaube, da war ihre Sperrinfrastruktur noch nicht so fortschrittlich und da wurde glaube ich mal eine Zeit lang ganz YouTube gesperrt, weil es da irgendwie ein Video drauf gab, in dem der Prophet verunglimpft wurde. Und das Wort auf der Straße war, dass diese Videos von Griechen hochgeladen wurden, um die Türken zu ärgern, damit der gesamten Türkei, der Zugang zu YouTube abgeschnitten wird. Inzwischen ist das nicht mehr so, dass sie die ganze YouTube sperren. Aber es war ja jetzt eine Ankündigung von Erdogan, der sagte, ja, heute Twitter und morgen Facebook und übermorgen die ganze Welt, übermorgen die Türkei nicht.
Nochmal zu dieser Reaktion von Twitter. Also diese Klage, die jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass dieses Sperrungsverfügung vorläufig zurückgenommen wurde, wurde unter anderem auch von Twitter selbst mit angestrengt. Das haben sie danach bekannt gegeben, nach Bekündigung dieses Ergebnisses oder Zwischenergebnisses. Und ich meine, das auch so verstanden zu haben, dass Twitter jetzt auch wohl erstmalig dieses vor einem Jahr bereits bekanntgegebene, wir können für einzelne Länder auch bestimmte Tweets ausblenden Feature jetzt aktiviert werden würde. Also die von Twitter ja quasi genau für diese Fälle, dass bestimmte Inhalte in einem Land legal gesperrt werden sollen. Ja, das haben sie ja vorgesehen, dass sie das jetzt eben auch für die Türkei dann wohl erstmalig an den Start bringen werden. Ha, ich hab jetzt noch keinen Bericht, wo das ist. Und das funktionierte ja so, dass sie quasi einzelne Tweets dann so mit dieser Inhalt ist in ihrem Land nicht verfügbar Style quasi rausnehmen, in anderen Ländern aber sehr wohl anzeigen. Also das war jetzt so ein neuer Aspekt. Ich hab jetzt noch keinen Bericht gesehen, dass sie das von irgendeinem Tweet gemacht hätten und ich frage mich eigentlich auch ehrlich gesagt, warum das so in der Form noch gar nicht aktiv war. Vielleicht ist jetzt einfach, gut, vielleicht hatte Twitter es nicht besonders eilig, dass es den Staaten quasi als Feature vorneweg zu verkaufen und jetzt erst im Rahmen dieser Eskalationsstufe machen sie das. Ist halt in dem Moment umgehbar, wo man in der Lage ist, über einen VPN eine ausländische IP-Adresse zu erhalten, aber...
Du hast recht, wir hatten das auch hier in der Sendung behandelt.
Ja, das war so eine Ankündigung von vor einem Jahr, glaube ich.
Interessant. Ja, das ist aber zum Beispiel ein sehr schöner, also es eignet sich sehr gut zur Überleitung, aber es ist auch ein schönes Beispiel von, ach so, okay, ihr wollt euren Dienst in unserem Land anbieten? Ja, kein Problem. Ich meine, so ein bisschen, wenn ihr euch selber zensiert, dann müssen wir euch nicht im Gegenzug ganz zensieren. Ist doch super.
Ja, also da kann man jetzt auch, da ist ja Twitter auch viel gescholten worden, als sie das bekannt gegeben haben, weil sie ja im Prinzip grundsätzlich schon mal gesagt haben, wir sehen die Realität, dass Zensur existiert, aber wir wollen zumindest eine Methode verhindern, eine Methode bieten, die verhindert, dass eben, wie jetzt, ja, der ganze Dienst gesperrt wird. Und wir wissen ja auch alle, ich meine, wenn dann halt ein einzelner Tweet mal verboten ist, dann wird das gegebenenfalls auch schnell festgestellt, weil dann kommt da die URL auf den Tweet, dann glässt du drauf, dann siehst du, ist nicht zu sehen, dann weißt du, ah, da steckt was dahinter, irgendjemand anderes kann dir dann aber diesen Tweet quasi retweeten und schon ist er dann doch wieder in einem Timeline, also es ist so ein bisschen Katz und Maus an der Stelle.
Es ist Katz und Maus, solange die großen Anbieter nicht mitmachen. Und bei der Zentralisierungstendenz, die wir irgendwie im Netz ja schon sehen, also auf den Dienst Twitter mit einer kleinen alternative app.net, auf den Dienst Facebook mit einer nicht mehr vorhandenen alternative Studieforts hätte, dann wird es natürlich unschön. Und wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen, dass zumindest Facebook ja sowieso schon nach eigenen Maßstäben da zensiert in ihrem Bereich.
Ja, ich meine, es wurde berichtet, dass viel auf Facebook ausgewichen sein soll.
Eine sehr schlaue Idee, sehr schlaue Idee.
Ja, was ich insofern immer sehr lustig finde, als das ja bei Facebook, das verstärkt sich ja gerade auch nur, man bei Design mittlerweile gar nicht davon ausgehen kann, dass alle Leute, die einen folgen, also wie das in einem Gesichtsbuch spricht heißt, liken.
Ach, muss man sich, muss man...
Man erreicht so in der Regel nur noch 20 Prozent seiner Follower. Also wenn du was postest, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass nur ein geringer Teil der Leute, die deinen Updates folgen wollen, diese Updates auch wirklich bekommen. Das ist zumindest so, wenn du wirklich eine große Zahl von Followern hast. Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist, wenn du so nur so 10 oder 20 hast, so Family and Friends, ob das dann auch an der Stelle auch schon greift. Ich vermute mal, es gibt da so ein Minimum, wo es immer durchkommt, aber in dem Moment, wo es relevante Zahlen sind, wo du wirklich ein relativ großes Publikum hast, erreichst du dieses Publikum nur dann, wenn du auch noch dafür bezahlst. Das ist wirklich so dermaßen haarsträubend und absurd. Ich verstehe auch überhaupt nicht, wie man sich auf so was einlassen kann, aber das ist die Facebook-Realität. Sie bieten allen Leuten kostenlos den Zugang, um ihnen dann quasi im zweiten Schritt wegzunehmen und sie dann dafür bezahlen zu lassen, dass sie ihn trotzdem noch bekommen.
Aber so funktioniert das doch. Also so etablierst du dich doch auf einem Markt.
Ja, und vor allem das Alberne ist, du kannst auch dafür bezahlen, dass du überhaupt erst noch mehr Follower bekommst, die du dann aber nicht erreichen kannst. Die dann nicht selten. Da gibt es auch interessante Blogposts, wo Leute das dann mal so nachgemessen haben. So, ja, hier, ich habe so und so viel in Werbung investiert, bei Facebook. Und habe dann irgendwie so, was weiß ich, Tausende von Usern, die alle irgendwie in Malaysia, Afrika, sonst wo rum sitzen, die aber selber überhaupt nicht aktiv sind. Also die alle so ein ganz merkwürdiges soziales Profil haben. Und du kannst ja dann auch die Reactions messen auf deine Nachrichten, die also einen sehr viel niedrigeren Interaktionsgrad dann haben mit deinen Nachrichten, als du das normalerweise gewohnt bist. Mit anderen Worten, das, wo sie vorgeben, gegen vorzugehen, nämlich dass irgendwelche schäbigen Firmen da dir Fake-Follower verkaufen. Ja, das machen sie einfach selber. Und am Ende hast du einfach von diesen ganzen Zahlen nichts. Deswegen glaube ich halt auch diesen ganzen Verbreitungszahlen, von denen immer ausgegangen wird bei Facebook, glaube ich halt einfach nicht. Bei Twitter ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass jeder deiner Follower sofort dankend jeden Tweet liest und darauf reagiert. Ganz klar, man ist halt mal nicht da, man gibt seine Timeline, was weiß ich. Aber zumindest hast du derzeit noch sehr wohl diese Logik, dass wenn dir jemand folgt, dann ist dein Tweet in dessen Timeline. Ob die dann gelesen wird und ob darauf reagiert wird, steht auf einem ganz anderen Blatt. Aber bei Facebook ist das mitnichten so. Und ja, insofern viel Spaß bei der nächsten Facebook-Revolution. Könnte sein, dass ein paar Leute nicht kommen.
Aber Tim, weißt du, was du gerade machst? Derailing. Du, keine Ahnung. Wir reden auf jeden Fall von was ganz anderes, als wir ursprünglich reden.
Ach du meinst, derail dein Thema.
Du derails.
Na wieso? Ich meine, wir reden über diese Problematik.
Facebook.
Ich meine, man könnte jetzt nur auf Sperren reduzieren. Ich würde eher sagen, dieser...
Inhaltlichen Einfluss machen...
.Illusion der netzgestützten Demokratiebewegung oder Illusion des Bekämpfens von Diktaturen etc. Und ich bin da ja auch gerne selber sozialromantisch. Hab auch vor ein paar Jahren mal eine Sendung bei Chaos Radio gemacht, die sich, glaube ich, Twitter Demokratie nannte. Das war so Arab Spring und so. Und da stehe ich im Prinzip auch noch dazu, zu den grundlegenden Thesen, dass natürlich überhaupt erst mal so eine soziale Vernetzung übers Netz an sich erst mal was Gutes ist. Und das bewirkt ja auch in der Türkei eine Menge. Also ich meine, wäre GESI etc. während dieser ganzen Demonstration, dieser Widerstand überhaupt möglich gewesen ohne diese Netzöffentlichkeit? Meiner Meinung nach nein. Hat der Staat Mittel in der Hand dagegen vorzugehen? Ja, definitiv. Wird es schlimmer? Ja, definitiv. Also wir haben es hier auch mit einem Aufrüsten zu tun, gerade weil da eben auch wirklich eine Bedrohung drin gesehen wird. Und so Staaten wie eben die Türkei jetzt unter der AKP-Partei zeigen eben sehr schön, wie auf der einen Seite das traditionelle Denken der Politik, nach dem Motto, wir sind jetzt hier in der Macht, jetzt hat das auch immer alles so zu laufen, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Und wie, da gibt es jetzt Möglichkeiten drum herum, hier unser Informationsmonopol auszuliebeln, da gehen wir mal gegen vor, wie das eben sehr schön zeigt, wie sich die Zeiten einfach auch wandeln. Und wie wir jetzt an so einem kritischen Punkt angekommen sind, wo die technologische Entwicklung zunächst einmal erstmal wieder gegen uns läuft. Im Sinne von all diese neuen Mittel, die gekommen sind, um sich zu vernetzen, können jetzt auch gegen uns verwendet werden. Im Sinne von nicht nur zweiter Öffentlichkeit, also ich meine auch Erdogan könnte ja seine Anhänger per Twitter genauso aufrufen. Könnte er ja machen, macht er vielleicht auch, weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Ich fand es schon bezeichnend, dass der Staatspräsident, dieser Gül, der auf Twitter sich dagegen beschwert hat, dass Twitter gesperrt wird. Das war schon echt ein Statement. Ja, also das ist jetzt einfach die Phase, in der wir sind. Und da muss man sich einfach bewusst sein, dass es eben mitnichten so ist, dass das alles leicht zu umgehen ist. Es kann sehr wohl sein, dass wir eine Situation erreichen, in der das alles sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig sein wird, diese Netzöffentlichkeiten aufrechtzuerhalten.
Ja, absolut, genau. Und das aus zwei Gründen. Einerseits, dass die Netz-, also die tatsächliche Provider-Zensur-Infrastruktur stärker wird. Und andererseits, dass wir in unseren zentralen Diensten ohnehin keine nennenswerte Netzöffentlichkeit mehr haben. Zumindest, wenn wir uns in den Bereich begeben, der außerhalb von Marketing ist und halt in Richtung gesellschaftlicher Veränderungen geht. Nächstes Thema. Wir machen heute Internet-Zensur-Basiswissen. Das ist das Thema der Sendung heute. Denn jetzt haben wir uns schon ein bisschen damit auseinandergesetzt, wie man das Internet beeinflussen kann, indem es den Inhalten, die es dem Nutzer durch seinen Provideranschluss noch zukommen lässt und nicht. Und was sich in diesen ganzen Zensur-Debatten, wenn man sie in Europa führt, dann geht es ja nie darum, wir müssen politisch missliebige Inhalte zensieren, sondern es geht immer wieder darum, dass wir Darstellungen dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauches nicht zugänglich machen wollen. Und natürlich die Schriften und Texte jener, die Terror über unser Land bringen wollen. Das sind ja so die beiden.
In ihrer Zirkulation einschränken möchten.
Bitte? Ich hab dich akustisch nicht verstanden.
Genau, achso, hab ich den Satz gar nicht beendet. Guck mal, so blöd bin ich. Das sind immer die Motivationen, die genannt werden. Und jetzt ist natürlich der Punkt, diese Debatten sollten in der Regel an der Stelle beendet sein, dass man sagt, okay, weder Kindesmissbrauchs, der illegal ist, wird öffentlich im Internet angeboten, noch terroristische Aufrufe werden, irgendwie im Internet öffentlich gemacht, also zumindest keine genaue Planung. Ich persönlich bin ja in meiner Einstellung zur Meinungsfreiheit radikal genug, zu sagen, okay, auch ein, wenn da irgendein so ein wirrer, wie heißt dieser rothaarige, Jean-Pierre Vogel oder was? Pierre Vogel, oder?
Ich weiß überhaupt gar nicht, von wem man das sagen will.
Ein deutscher islamistischer Prediger, der zum sunnitischen Islam konvertierte und da irgendwie so relativ wirre Gedanken äußerte. Ich finde das super, dass der die äußert und äußern darf. Und ich finde das auch okay, dass der sich auf irgendeinem Dorfplatz stellt und dem 20 Mann irgendwie zuhören und 150 Mann entgegenschreien und sagen, du hast ja wohl einen Vogel. Aber okay, andere sehen das anders. Andere halten den für gemeingefährlich und sagen, man muss den zensieren. Ich weiche schon wieder ab. Mensch, das wird heute eine Sendung der Abweichung. Worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist, es gibt ja Fälle, in denen man sagt, es wäre ja gut, bestimmte Inhalte für bestimmte Nutzergruppen nicht zugänglich zu machen. Und zwar ohne politische Motivationen. Und da sind wir dann im Bereich des Jugendschutzes, wo Menschen der Ansicht sind, dass es Inhalte gibt, die verbreitet werden oder verbreitet werden könnten, welche schädlich für das seelische Wohl unserer nachwachsenen Generationen sind und dann die Kinder kaputt machen.
Es geht natürlich auch noch ein bisschen weiter. Das ist immer so ein bisschen der Klassiker in der Diskussion, dass man sagt, ihr wollt ja nur hier Terroransprache und ihr wollt, wie soll ich sagen, KIPO-related Content verhindern. Das geht ja glaube ich bei dieser ganzen Jugendmedienschutzgeschichte auch so ein bisschen da drum.
Das war jetzt der Climax der Überleitung. Wir sind langsam, die Überleitung erreicht jetzt ihren Höhepunkt. Jetzt ist schon das Wort gefallen, worauf wir hinaus wollen. Nur noch wenige Minuten, dann haben wir es geschafft.
Zum neuen Thema zu kommen.
Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag.
Aber die Intention ist ja hier auch durchaus nachvollziehbar in der Debatte. Es gibt ja auch Fedder, Systeme, Chatsysteme, Chaträume etc. die sich speziell auch an Kinder wenden. Also die auch sagen, dass sie das sind. Wo dann so Problematiken der etwas fragwürdigen Anbahnung von Kontakten eine Rolle spielt. Das hängt halt alles in diesem Gesamtkomplex mit drin, wo eben der Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag schon länger versucht, eine Lösung zu finden zwischen den Parteien.
Absolut korrekt wäre, es wird versucht, eine Lösung zu finden, denn den Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag gibt es auch heute schon. Den gibt es seit seiner letzten Novellierung seit 2002. Und in dieser Form ist er auch noch gültig. Jetzt kann man sich vorstellen, wie es um das Internet um 2002 bestellt war und wie sehr realitätsfremd bestimmte Formulierungen in diesem Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag unter heutiger Perspektive erscheinen. Und es wurde 2010 schon der Versuch gemacht, eine Novellierung dieses Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrages herbeizuführen. Und die Herausforderung, die man in diesem Falle sieht, ist, wenn wir jetzt mal als gegeben annehmen, dass es bestimmte Inhalte im Internet gibt, von denen Eltern ihre Kinder gerne fernhalten wollen. Über Sinn und Unsinn, davon brauchen wir glaube ich nicht zu diskutieren, weil da werden wir keine Meinungsänderungen herbeiführen. Wenn man jetzt annimmt, dass man das möchte, dann wäre es jetzt zum Beispiel der Punkt, dass Eltern sagen, ich installiere auf dem Rechner, der meinem Kind zugänglich ist, ein Programm, welches eine Inhaltskontrolle vornimmt und bestimmte Inhalte nicht zugänglich macht. Oder man könnte sich auch vorstellen, dass dieses Programm auf der Fritzbox aktiviert wird. Da gibt es glaube ich schon so einen Checkmark, Jugendschutzfilter. Oder dass man das vielleicht sogar beim Provider aktivieren lässt, um die Umgehungsmöglichkeiten des Kindes noch stärker einzuschränken, sofern das Kind tatsächlich bestrebt sein sollte, diese Sperren dann auch zu umgehen. Und das Problem für einen Anbieter solcher Jugendschutzprogramme ist, dass er ja wissen muss, wie sieht es da draußen in diesem Internet aus, wo dürfen Kinder hin und wohin nicht. Und prinzipiell, wenn man jetzt anfängt, so etwas zu machen, dann kann man sich zwischen zwei Ansätzen entscheiden. Der eine heißt White-Listing.
Nur durch das, was explizit als gut markiert ist?
Man sperrt einfach mal das gesamte Internet und lässt nur das durch, was irgendwie man für gut und in Ordnung hält. Oder man macht Blacklisting, das heißt, man sperrt nur das, was besonders schlecht ist. Ist natürlich klar, beim White-Listing habe ich das Problem, dass ich eine ganze Menge nicht jugendgefährdende Schriften meinen Nutzern nicht zugänglich mache. Und beim Blacklisting habe ich das Problem, dass ich einen sehr löchrigen Filter habe, nämlich eventuell es sehr viele Inhalte gibt, die mir nicht bekannt sind, die ich dann meinen Nutzern zugänglich mache. Was wahrscheinlich schon die meisten sind. Genau, das ist wahrscheinlich der größere Teil. Also beide Ansätze führen dazu, dass die Kunden mit dem Produkt nicht zufrieden sein werden. Und wenn man sich jetzt die Größe des Internets anschaut, wird das Problem auch nicht kleiner. Diese Arten von Filter hat man schon um die Jahrtausendwende nicht vernünftig hinbekommen. Da hatte ich mal einige Monate das Glück, hinter einem solchen Filter zu sitzen und mich in Zensurumgehungen zu üben. Und wie gesagt, das Problem ist seitdem nicht geschrumpft, sondern eher sehr viel größer geworden. Und was man sich jetzt überlegt hat ist, wir könnten ja quasi per Gesetz die Anbieter der Seiten dazu bringen, mit anderen Worten zwingen, dass sie ihre eigenen Inhalte, die ja für sie immer noch halbwegs überblickbar sein sollten, nach Alterskategorien klassifizieren und diese zum Beispiel im HTML-Header...
Ja, so wie das Filme machen. Freigegeben ab 6, nur mit elterlicher Begleitung etc.
Genau, und dann können die Eltern im Prinzip, da wir ja jetzt irgendwie von Computern reden, wenn dann der Computer gesagt kriegt, ach guck mal hier dieser Inhalt ist ab 12, dein Nutzer ist aber gerade eingestellt mit 8 Jahren, also stell dir mal bitte diesen Inhalt nicht dar. Das heißt, dann wäre das möglich, so einen Jugendschutz tatsächlich funktional zu bekommen. Wie gesagt, man muss nur die Nutzer natürlich alle per unter Androhung hoher Strafen, die Anbieter unter Androhung hoher Strafen, dazu bringen, diese Inhalteklassifizierung vorzunehmen, und dann könnte das funktionieren. Dann könnten also die kommerziellen Anbieter von Internetfiltern dann von dieser gesetzlich erzwungenen Mithilfe der Inhalteanbieter profitieren und hätten dann ein Produkt, welches sie tatsächlich auf dem Markt anbieten können und wo sie eventuell auch Abnehmer für finden. Das finde ich ist hier ein entscheidender Punkt, denn es handelt sich mal wieder um eine relativ gehörige Portion und Wirtschaftsförderung, die da eine Rolle spielt. Denn eigentlich würde ich ja sagen, ich meine so ein komisches Internet-Sperrprodukt, das ist relativ einfach zu bauen. Die Dienstleistung, für die ich zahle, ist ja dann die Katalogisierung, die dieser Anbieter vornimmt. Und wenn er selbst das nicht mehr machen muss, ist es für diesen Anbieter natürlich ein sehr lukratives Geschäftsmodell, weil er nichts hat, was er großartig pflegen muss. Genau so etwas soll jetzt mit dem Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag erreicht werden, dass quasi die Anbieter mithelfen, ihre Inhalte zu klassifizieren.
Die Diskussion ist ja nicht neu.
Vor 2010 wurde die erste Novelle angestrebt und ist dann damals nach langen Debatten gescheitert, und zwar am Votum des Landes Nordrhein-Westfalen. Ich weiß das noch, wir hatten hier in Berlin, hätten wir es fast geschafft, damals Berlin noch von Linken und SPD regiert, da hätte man es schaffen können, dass die Linken, die gegen diesen JMS-TV waren, ihr Votum dagegenbringen, und so durch so dann keine Mehrheit zustande kommt, und dieser JMS-TV stolpern würde. Das ist aber in Berlin nicht passiert, weil die Linken Angst hatten, dass die SPD ihnen dann eine vereinbarte Besserstellung von Hartz IV-Empfängern nicht durchgehen lassen würde. Genau, dieser typische politische Deal. Zu ihrer Entschuldigung haben die Linken aber dann auch hervorgebracht, dass würden sie dagegen stimmen, im Zweifelsfall die CDU, die ja auch mit drin sitzt, allerdings in dem Fall dann der Opposition, in der Opposition trotzdem dafür stimmen würde. Das heißt, diese gesamte Situation war für die Linke in Berlin sehr unangenehm und ihrer Glaubwürdigkeit nicht zuträglich, weil sie mussten am Ende dafür stimmen, obwohl sie dagegen waren. Das konnten sie natürlich sehr schwer verkaufen. Letztendlich ist es aber dann, mir sind die umständlich mehr hundertprozentig präsent am Votum von NRW gescheit, und dann kam der nicht zustande. Also das ist die Geschichte, die wir jetzt schon hatten. Jetzt will ich aber erklären, warum ist er nicht zustande gekommen. Das lag daran, dass dieser schönen Theorie einige Probleme anhaften. Nämlich, was ist...
Der schönen Theorie der einfachen Sperrung.
Genau, der einfachen Klassifizierung. Denn was passiert, wenn ein Anbieter seine Inhalte falsch klassifiziert? In der Novelle von 2010 sollte es noch sehr viele Alterstufen geben. Da war es, glaube ich, irgendwie 6, 8, 12, 16, 18 oder so. Und dann macht man die korrekte Unterscheidung zwischen 16 und 18. In dem Entwurf, den man jetzt heute hat, ist es nur noch die Unterscheidung zwischen 6 und 12. Also 6, 12 und 18. Ach so, nee, 12 und 18. Aber das heißt, es wird ein großes Haftungsproblem für die kleinen Inhalteanbieter. Also beispielsweise Logbuch Netzpolitik. Stell dir mal vor, in irgendeiner dieser Sendungen würde ich irgendwie auf einmal plötzlich Sau sagen. Was Unflettiges. Jetzt müsste plötzlich diese Sendung, jetzt würden wir sagen, ach Sau, kann man doch mal sagen. Weil jetzt gibt es vielleicht andere, die sagen, Sau kann man in dem Zusammenhang nicht sagen. Und dann ist halt die Frage, ist dieses Sau jetzt ab 12 oder ab 18? Und wenn wir uns da jetzt in der Klassifizierung irren würden, dann würden wir also dafür haften. Das heißt, was macht der kleine Inhalteanbieter? Er zieht natürlich einfach zur Sicherheit das Ganze auf ab 18, kann Spuren von expliziter Sprache beinhalten und entgeht so dem Problem, dass er da mit einem Bußgeld bedacht werden könnte. Was dann wiederum die wirklich ungewünschte Folge hat, dass unsere nachfolgende Generation, die Kinder, der Nährboden unserer Zukunft, Logbuch Netzpolitik nicht hören könnten. Wäre ja auch jetzt nicht so gut. Das stimmt. Weiteres großes Problem ist, wir haben auch Kommentare, user-generated content. Das heißt, was einem Besucher der Seite logbuchnetzpolitik.de angezeigt wird, ist nicht immer vollständig unter unserer Kontrolle. Wir werden also dann gezwungen, die Kommentare zu moderieren und auch da wieder Abwägungen zu treffen. Und jetzt stell dir mal vor, jetzt hast du da eine kommentiert, eine zur Sendung von vor drei Wochen. Die haben wir als ab 6 klassifiziert, weil wir uns relativ sicher waren, dass keine bösen Wörter und keine allzu zum Terrorismus motivierenden Äußerungen getätigt wurden. Und jetzt schreibt da jemand etwas drunter und wir müssen dann eine Klassifikation vornehmen und sagen, oh, dieser Kommentar ist allerdings erst ab 18. Wollen wir die jetzt riskieren, dass wir unsere gesamte Sendung hochstufen müssen? Also es ist letztendlich dann nicht realisierbar.
Die sind nämlich extrem kinderkompatibel hier, aber es sind nur die Kommentare, die das Ganze hier machen.
Die Kommentare reißen das jedes Mal ab 21. Berli, Alter, Berli-Liegel. Naja, und dann kommt noch ein anderes Problem dazu. Was macht jetzt sowas wie Facebook, wo du gerade schon sagtest, wo für jeden einzelnen Nutzer zusammengewürfelt wird aus den Leuten, oder Twitter, aus den Leuten, die sie jeweils folgen, dann müsste quasi jeder einzelne Tweet oder jeder einzelne Facebook, wie heißt das? Status bei Facebook? Facebook-Post, jeder einzelne Facebook-Post in seiner Jugendkompatibilität beurteilt werden.
Ja, das wird ja auch teilweise. Dann kannst du ja mal anfangen, Bilder mit politischen Femen-Aktivistinnen zu posten und so weiter. Die Nachrichtenagenturen da, so Bild und so weiter, die retuschieren die Nippel da schon vorher raus, bevor das irgendwie auf Facebook geht.
Nee, das war umgekehrt. Die Leute, die die Femen-Bilder auf Facebook geladen haben, haben ihre Nippelchen da raus retuschiert, damit das Bild überhaupt auf Facebook kommt und die Nachrichtenagenturen von Facebook runtergehen.
Genau, also es muss auf jeden Fall garantiert nippelfrei sein und sonst geht es da halt irgendwie nicht durch. Na ja, ich meine, Facebook wäre zumindest in der Lage mit den ganzen Datumsangaben etc., die ja dann quasi deinen Strom auch gleich entsprechend kindgerecht dazu bringen.
Facebook, okay, Facebook lass ich gelten, aber für, sag ich mal, kleine Inhalteanbieter stellt dann dieses bestrebendes Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrags ein großes Problem dar. Ganz zu schweigen davon, dass das ja sowieso wieder nur für Deutschland gelten würde. Ja, es ist so wunderbar, so großartig. Das heißt, wir würden natürlich anfangen, ins Ausland umzuziehen, um weiterhin unsere Inhalte anbieten zu können.
Ja, was ist denn jetzt die Alternative?
Mir fällt keine funktionierende, keine wirklich funktionierende Alternative ein. Die Alternative, die heute tatsächlich aktiv ist, versuch mal einen Tatort zu schauen, jetzt in der IED-Mediathek. Der wird dir nicht ausgestrahlt werden über das Internet, weil es eine Sendezeitbeschränkung gibt. Und das ist eine Sendung ab, was weiß ich, 12 oder 16 oder sowas. Und die darf erst nach 20 Uhr ausgestrahlt werden. Das ist die Alternative. Und das ist, wenn man das Telemediengesetz streng liest, die momentane Tatsache, dass man versucht, dass Kinder zu bestimmten Zeiten schlafen gehen, als Grundvoraussetzung für Jugendschutz genommen wird. Und man sagt, vor bestimmten Uhrzeiten dürfen bestimmte Inhalte nicht zugehend gemacht werden.
Auch wenn wir uns hier immer mit Guten Morgen begrüßen, gehört werden darf diese Sendung natürlich erst nach 21 Uhr, wenn die Kinder schlafen.
Richtig, weil wir sagen ja manchmal SAU.
Ja, oder noch schlimmeres.
SAU. ARSCH. Ne, aber es ist jetzt ne...
Mach mal das Explicit-Tag an.
Das ist natürlich, das ist ein Problem. Also es ist tatsächlich ein Problem. Es lässt sich nicht wirklich umsetzen. Und die Verfechter dieser Novelle sagen eben auch, ja, dass das Problem ist im Moment eigentlich noch schlechter gelöst oder nicht gelöst.
Also du meinst, es gibt eigentlich auch überhaupt gar keinen Vorschlag, den man machen kann. Ich meine, da wird sich diese Diskussion natürlich wunderbar im Kreis drehen, weil es einfach immer wieder die Front gibt der Leute, die sagen, da muss doch mal was gemacht werden. Es kann ja nicht sein, dass da nichts getan werden kann.
Also es gab, es gibt so ein, ich habe, also damals, 2010 gab es dann halt auch diese Debatte um irgendwie Öffnungszeiten, ne? Denn dieses, diese Text, dass man jetzt sagt, die Altersklassifikation ist implizit im HTML kodiert oder so, hat ja zur Folge, dass immer noch die Gegenseite einen Filter gezielt zur Anwendung bringen muss. Und das heißt, es wäre immer noch das Problem der Durchdringung. Das heißt, erstmal würde sich ja gar nichts ändern. So und jetzt könnte man natürlich das Spiel weiterspielen und sagen, okay, per Default musst du aber dafür sorgen, dass deine Inhalte zu den bestimmten Uhrzeiten auch nicht erreichbar sind. Das heißt, du musst Öffnungszeiten quasi für deine Webseite machen. Aber ist das Quatsch? Das ist ziemlicher Quatsch, aber das waren tatsächlich Realitäten, die damals 2010 genauso diskutiert wurden. Öffnungszeiten fürs Internet. Also wie gesagt, ARD Mediathek, schaust dir an, funktioniert gerade genauso.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir jetzt noch irgendwas Produktives zu dieser Debatte beitragen können.
Ich glaube, wir haben so das Grundprinzip erklärt. Ich glaube, ich gehöre ja vielleicht zu der ersten, ja doch, klar, ich gehöre zu einer Generation, nämlich jeder Generation, die im Jugendalter Zugang zum Internet hatte. Das hatten ja andere nicht in ihrer Kindheit. Und ich hatte auch freien Zugang zum Internet. Ja, also ich muss sagen, ich hab da sicherlich auch einige Sachen angeschaut, die man nach heutigen Prinzip vielleicht sogar echt schon ab 12 kategorisieren würde. Oder vielleicht sogar wach sein.
Und wie war's?
Ich weiß, also größtenteils fand ich das immer sehr interessant. Aber so einige Seiten gibt es ja auch im Internet, wo ich jetzt sagen würde, es wäre jetzt auch nicht schlimm gewesen, wenn ich die nicht gesehen hätte. Hätte meine Entwicklung wahrscheinlich nicht nachteilig beeinflusst, wenn ich jetzt bestimmte Seiten nicht gesehen hätte. Aber auch für die Jugend haben wir natürlich dieses Problem, dass gesperrte Sachen eben besonders interessant werden. Ich will mich da nicht positionieren. Ich sehe im Moment, würde ich die Situation so einschätzen, dass die Probleme, die die momentan technisch vorgeschlagenen Lösungen hervorbringen würden, größer sind als die Probleme, die dadurch entstehen, wenn...
Dass es nicht... dass es zugänglich ist.
Dass es zugänglich ist, ja. Ich denke, dass es wahrscheinlich sinnvoller wäre, aber da kann man sich wiederum nicht darauf verlassen, dass man sagt, okay, es wäre der Anspruch, dass die Inhalte technisch gefiltert werden, glaube ich, der ist nicht sinnvoll zu erfüllen. Ich denke, man sollte eher den Anspruch betonen, dass die Eltern sich irgendwie vernünftig um ihre Kinder kümmern und irgendwie ihr heranwachsen in diese Medienlandschaft, die jetzt doch echt eine ziemlich irre und wirre und geile Medienlandschaft ist in heutigen Zeiten, dass die Eltern ihre Kinder da begleiten, dass die pädagogischen Institutionen die Kinder dabei begleiten. Ich denke, das wäre etwas, was eine sehr viel größere Notwendigkeit hat.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht so sicher, ob wirklich jeder auch in der Lage ist, diese Begleitung in der Form wirklich auch vorzunehmen.
Und das ist genau das Problem, das sind wahrscheinlich die meisten Eltern nicht.
Ja, also ob die Frage, was einen da groß qualifiziert, weil auch dieses, ja man soll ja dabei sein und so weiter, irgendwann bist du einfach auch nicht mehr dabei. Das geht ja besonders in dem Moment, wenn man sich immer noch so, der Desktop-Computer im Wohnzimmer, wo man dann gemeinsam wie eins vom Fernseher vor dem Internet sitzt und so kennt, jetzt zeige ich dir mal das Internet, hier ist die erste Seite, hier ist die zweite Seite, hier ist die dritte Seite und dies aber bäh. Ja, und wenn sowas schon kommt, dann machst du gleich weg. The times are over, man. Jetzt laufen die Zehnjährigen mit Smartphones durch die Gegend und the world at your fingertips. Und da ist dann so mit dabei sein und einführen irgendwie nicht mehr, das ist einfach nicht mehr gegeben. Und an der Stelle ist glaube ich auch eine Kontrolle irgendwie Quatsch, weil wir wissen, wir haben es schon dargelegt, also diese Zensur funktioniert nicht. Irgendwie muss man wahrscheinlich damit klarkommen. Das klingt jetzt allerdings auch sehr fatalistisch, weil ich würde ja auch nicht sagen, dass wir hier keinerlei Probleme zu erwarten hätten. Also man muss schon irgendwie einen Weg finden, das für alle händelbar zu gestalten. Aber ich habe auch keine gute Antwort darauf, wie.
Zu dem momentanen Entwurf des Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrages, der unter der Federführung des Landes Sachsen stattfindet, gibt es die Möglichkeit, Ideen und Vorschläge einzubringen. Da gibt es dann einen Link, hier geht es zu ihren Beteiligungsmöglichkeiten. Da kann man also bei Diskussionen mitwirken. Also Jugendmedienschutzstaatsvertrag, das ist so richtig schön Retro-Netzpolitik. Pre-Snowden-Netzpolitik, wo man so schön über Zensurmöglichkeiten redet, wo man richtig schön stark unsinnige Gesetzesentwürfe hat, die es zu korrigieren gilt. Das war 2010, echt ein großes Thema. Da haben ja Leute aufgehört zu bloggen im Protest gegen diese Öffnungszeiten, was dann noch groß diskutiert wurde. Dass man gezwungen sein könnte, seinem Blog Öffnungszeiten zu verpassen. Und wo wir so schön heute schon eine Sondersendung zu Netzsperren machen und wie man Leuten den Zugang zum Internet kaputt machen kann. Da hat sich natürlich dann auch direkt der EuGH ein Urteil zu Ehren dieser Sendung einfallen lassen und heute veröffentlicht. Denn die haben jetzt entschieden, dass Netzsperren ein probates Mittel sein können, um Urheberrechtsschutz zu gewährleisten. Das war ein Verfahren zwischen einem österreichischen Telefonanbieter, der UPC Telekabel Wien GmbH, und der Konstantin Filmverleih und Vega Filmproduktionsgesellschaft, wo in Österreich angeordnet wurde, dass die Webseite Kino.to gesperrt wird. Und es sollte jetzt verhandelt werden, ob überhaupt Netzsperren zur Durchsetzung von Urheberrechtsansprüchen Dritter ein probates Mittel sind, das ein Gericht anordnen darf. Und da gab es schon, irgendwie letztes Jahr war das, da hatten wir auch glaube ich darüber gesprochen, da hatte unser Freund Pedro Cruz Villalon, der EU-EUGH-Generalanwalt, seinen Schlussantrag formuliert, in dem er gesagt hat, ja, also Sperrverfügung können in bestimmten klar begründeten Fällen ein angemessenes Mittel zum Schutz von Urheberrechten sein. Und wie wir es jetzt auch schon in Hinblick auf das Vorratsdatenspeicherungsurteil kennen, seiner Schlussantrag wird auch gerne gefolgt und das hat der EUGH auch jetzt getan.
Das heißt, es gibt jetzt vom EUGH, wo man sich eigentlich viel verspricht, im Hinblick auf Vorratsdatenspeicherung, genau hier die Aussage, ja, damit das verhindert werden kann, kann man auch mal was sperren. Das ist natürlich wirklich ein schlimmes Urteil.
Das ist ein sehr schlimmes Urteil, weil es eben jetzt in der Form erstmal sperren, also europaweit für okay.
Jetzt ist die Filmoindustrie auf jeden Fall wieder in 1,5-8 Stellung und wird jetzt...
Nein, noch nicht so ganz. Also es gibt halt noch einen kleinen Silberstreif Hoffnung am Horizont, nämlich die EU-Telekommunikationsverordnung, auch bekannt als Netzneutralitätsverordnung, die ja nächste Woche am 3. April durchs Parlament gewunken werden soll. Wir erinnern uns, dass es genau die Verordnung, für die der Thomas sich gerade so besonders einsetzt. Und in der könnte ja auch formuliert werden, dass Sperren grundsätzlich illegal sind. Dann würde dieses Urteil gar nicht erst zum Tragen kommen. Da ist jetzt nochmal der Hinweis, dass es besonders wichtig wäre, sich nochmal an dieser safetyinternet.eu-Fax-E-Mail und Anrufkampagne zu beteiligen. Das größere Problem ist, dass diese Sperren, wo er jetzt sagt, für Urheberrecht ist das in Ordnung, ich meine, das wird im Zweifelsfall jetzt dazu führen, oder es wird jenen als Motivation gelten, die das nicht nur wegen Urheberrechts sperren wollen, sondern eben wegen der bereits angesprochenen Probleme, Terrorismus, Aufruf und dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch, also tatsächlich gesetzlich illegale Inhalte. Das darf man nicht verbreiten, da gibt es also Gesetze gegen diese Verbreitung. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, es bietet sich natürlich an, diesen Inhalten dann auch mit Sperren zu begegnen, was ja in Deutschland unter diesem Beispiel ZensurSolar eben 2008, 2009 so breit diskutiert wurde und so viele Menschen politisiert hat oder Netz politisiert hat. Und genau dafür könnte das für derartige Sperren auch eine Vorlage sein, dass man sagt, wenn wir es schon für Urheberrechtsverletzungen machen, dann ja wohl sowieso für die Wahrung der Interessen, die unsere schon bestehenden Strafgesetze verfolgen. Dazu ist natürlich anzumerken, wenn es sich wirklich um illegale Inhalte handelt, dann ist natürlich das Löschen der Inhalte und eine entsprechende Strafverfolgung immer zu bevorzugen. Wie es ja auch bei Kino.to geschehen ist, wollen wir ja nicht vergessen. Da hatten wir ja darüber gesprochen, dass Kino.to nicht unbedingt die Helden des freien Netzes waren. Die haben Urheberrechtsverletzungen kommerzialisiert und industrialisiert. Menschen dafür bezahlt, diese Filme abzufilmen und Inhalte für diese Seiten da zu schaffen. Das waren jetzt echt nicht die großen Helden. Das Problem, das jetzt nur am Rande ist natürlich, dass jemand, der sich an einem Torrent beteiligt, quasi das gleiche Gesetz bricht, nachdem die Kino.to-Leute dann eben illegal gehandelt haben. Nämlich das massenhafte Verbreiten und Zugänglichmachen nach kommerziellem Maßstab. Und darunter fällt ja leider, nach aktueller Rechtsprechung eben dieses gemeinsame Teilen in BitTorrent-Schwärmen eben leider auch. Aber was also die tatsächlichen illegalen Inhalte und die wirklich gesellschaftsschädlichen Inhalte wie eben dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch und Aufruf zu Terrorismus angeht, da ist also zu bevorzugen, dass eine Strafverfolgung stattfindet, dass diejenigen, die diese Inhalte generiert haben, ausfindig gemacht werden und vor allem, dass die Inhalte gelöscht werden. Das war immer diese Forderung der Zensurgegner löschen statt zu sperren. Auch da kann man das genauso auf grau Bereiche ausweiten, wie jetzt DNS-Sperren. Das passiert auch regelmäßig. Das will jetzt niemanden motivieren, aber wenn bei einem Provider eine Abuse-Meldung eingeht, dass bestimmte Inhalte, die auf dessen Web-Server liegen, irgendwelche Rechte oder Gesetze verletzen würden, dann wird da nicht lange geprüft. Also da gibt es eine kurze Augenscheinsprüfung und dann sind die Dinger weg. Das geht relativ schnell. Das ist unter Umständen, wenn da jemand Missbrauch mit betreibt, natürlich auch sehr ärgerlich für diejenigen, die diese Inhalte bereitstellen. Das ist andererseits ein wichtiges Argument gegen den guten Herrn Zierke, der ja damals auch bei irgendeiner Bundestagsratsanhörung dann da groß erzählt hat, wie fürchterlich das ist, dass ihre Löschanträge und so alles überhaupt nicht, in dem wird ja alles gar nicht begegnet und die Provider geben Daten nicht raus und löschen Inhalte nicht. Das ist also eigentlich totaler Unsinn. Wie gesagt, so dokumentierter Kindesmissbrauch ist glaube ich in keinem Land der Welt legal. Ich glaube, es gibt ein Land, in dem er nicht explizit illegal ist. Da ist aber einfach jede Darstellung von nackten Menschen schon irgendwie Todesstrafe. Insofern, Todesstrafe war jetzt übertrieben, aber die haben da eine sehr rigide Gesetzgebung, in der dann gar nicht mehr unterschieden werden muss. Das heißt, es gibt kein Land der Erde, wo solche Inhalte geduldet werden. Und wenn man da eine Abuse-Meldung schreibt, dann dauert das nur sehr kurz, bis die Inhalte auch verschwunden sind.
Ja, das Missbrauchspotenzial bei Urheberrechtsverstößen ist ja auch sehr groß. Da brauchen wir nur die letzten Wochen und Monate hier nochmal zurückschauen. Ja, also Innenministerium verhindert die Versuch zu verhindern, dass interne Dokumente veröffentlicht werden mit dem Argument von Urheberrecht. Häufig gibt es diesen Fall, was weiß ich, Polizei-Übergriffe, Video auf YouTube, wurde gesperrt, weil im Hintergrund dudelt irgendeine urheberrechtsbehaftete Musik, die mit dem ganzen Vorfall nichts zu tun hat. Also das sind alles solche Sachen. Im Prinzip sind das ja auch schon Klassiker. Ich meine, das allererste Mal, dass wir diese Fälle hatten, das war ja, du erinnerst dich vielleicht noch, Vage, so Anonymous-Remailer-Systeme in Schweden, die dann von Scientology verklagt wurden, auch eben alles über Urheberrechtshebel. Ich sage ja gar nicht, dass es nicht Fälle gibt, wo durchaus nachvollziehbare Belange, die auf Urheberrechtsgesetzgebung basieren, von Firmen vorkommen. Kino.to ist dann sicherlich eher ein gutes Beispiel. Aber es ist halt grundsätzlich schwierig, das Ganze auf Sperrbasis zu machen. Und von daher ist dieses Urteil des EuGH zumindest problematisch.
Auf das auf jeden Fall. Also wie gesagt, wir hoffen, und es ist zu hoffen, dass die Telekommunikationsverordnung diesem Problem irgendwie zuvorkommt, dass dieses Urteil jetzt Schule macht. Aber sie hätten sich keinen besseren Zeitpunkt aussuchen können, um dieses Urteil zu verkünden, während irgendwie die gesamte westliche Welt da irgendwie einen riesen Foffo macht und ihre Hände reinwäscht in der Twitter-Sperre der Türkei und alle sagen du, du, du, das ist aber ganz fürchterlich. Und gleichzeitig hat die gesamte EU sich gerade Netzsperren als probates Mittel zur Durchsetzung von Urheberrechtsansprüchen durchgehen lassen. Was ja übrigens, also das war jetzt dieser österreichische Fall, aber die Liste der Länder, in denen irgendwie The Pirate Bay geblockt wird, die ja noch nicht mal tatsächlich das Urheberrecht verletzen, sondern nur den Menschen sehr gut dabei helfen, das zu tun. Die Liste dieser Länder ist lang. Und die Liste der Länder, wo Pirate Bay noch Domains anmelden kann, wird immer kürzer. Die ziehen ja andauernd um. Die Jungs sind da auch echt im Grabenkampf. Den sollte man eigentlich mal ein Flatter oberschieben. Ja, also so viel zu Netzsperren. Keine schöne Sache. Und auch da wieder, wenn ich da vielleicht noch ganz abschließend noch was zu Netzsperren sagen darf, dann ist das nämlich das, wir sehen, wir müssen das einerseits, diesen Kampf immer wieder auf der politischen Ebene führen und diese Gesetze abschmettern. Vielleicht sogar mal einen Sieg erlangen, wo wir das, wo wir diese, dieses ewig wiederkehrende Problem der Netzsperren auch mal eindämmen. Irgendwie signifikant, das ist uns bis jetzt ja nicht gelungen. Im Gegenteil, wenn wir uns das heutige Urteil anschauen. Aber wir werden wohl auch nicht umhin kommen, unsere Netznutzung da mal irgendwie zu überdenken und uns eben darum zu kümmern, dass wir entsprechende zensurresistente Alternativen schaffen, die vor allem auch in diesen Mainstream geraten. Natürlich sind die zensurresistenten Alternativen irgendwie, werden dann natürlich hauptsächlich von entsprechenden Urheberrechtsverletzern und anderen kriminellen Bevorzug genutzt, weil sie ihnen einen Vorteil bieten. Aber wir sehen eben, wie einschneidender die Eingriffe in anderen Ländern und auch irgendwann in unserem Land sein können und werden, wenn wir uns da nicht darum kümmern, das technisch jetzt zu erschweren, weil diesen politischen Kampf, auf den kann man sich offensichtlich nicht verlassen. Also nicht ausschließlich verlassen.
Sonst gibt es doch noch Öffnungszeiten im Internet.
Ja, oder eben out of business.
Leider geschlossen. Wir sollten unserem Podcast auch noch mal Öffnungszeiten verpassen. Und die sind jetzt gerade vorbei.
So sieht es aus. Das war mit der Wirste-Podcast, den wir hier hatten. Aber wir sind ja auch beide ein bisschen krank. Deswegen dürfen wir das gerade.
Das war schon der Würste. Echt? Dann geht es ja noch.
Ich habe nicht gesagt der Würste. Habe ich das gesagt?
Einer der.
Einer der? Nenne die Top 5 Würsten-Podcasts von Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Ja, das könnte schwierig werden. Aber euer Beitrag dazu in den Kommentaren.
Bitte jugendfrei.
Wir leisten uns da auf jeden Fall auch immer wieder mal eine etwas andere Sendungsgestaltung. Ist ja auch mal was. Sonst bleibt man ja viel zu verhaftet und hängen in seinen Strukturen. Das wollen wir ja auch nicht. Gibt es noch irgendwelche Termine, Ankündigungen, Ausblicke? Mir fällt gerade nichts ein. Wir haben ja letztes Mal schon Veranstaltungen angekündigt. Das gilt nach wie vor. Ansonsten habe ich jetzt nichts Neues auf der Liste.
Du? Nee, ich auch nicht. Im Moment noch nicht. Wir können ja sehen. Vielleicht kommt da noch was.
Dann bleibt uns nur den Wunsch zu äußern, dass ihr uns auch weiterhin gewogen bleibt und Spaß habt an der Weltrettung.
Und wenn ich am Anfang vergessen habe zu danken, ist der gute Stefan. Dem danke ich nämlich auch. Nee, hab ich letzte Woche vergessen zu danken. Der war gar nicht anonym. Tschüss.